Hello everybody, this is session 10 of our cancer class.
This class, we're going to get some some technical things.
These are slides that I usually use to teach doctors,
so I'm going to try, but I'm asked to make them really super simple.
Now we talked about in some earlier slides that our immune system usually kills the cancer.
And what I say usually, I really mean it does usually kill the cancer,
because we have cells in our body, maybe on a daily basis,
that have blocked apoptotic pathways,
and that are going through rapid replication,
and our immune system destroys them,
and we'd ever get cancer.
So I've said before, the say that everybody has cancer
is really a truism that because cancer is defined as a cell that going through apoptosis,
it is stuck in rapid replication.
So that's the definition of cancer.
Why does it everybody get cancer, have an expression of cancer,
where they have a diagnosis of cancer?
Well, that's increasing, but the reason why everybody doesn't get cancer
is because that person who did get cancer has an immune system
that's able to clean up these cells that are going rogue, and it's destroying them.
But with somebody with a diagnosis of cancer,
then they'll ask the question, and they rightfully should,
well, why did my immune system kill the cancer cells?
So why don't immune cells kill cancer cells perfectly?
Maybe I should change that to perfectly in a real life,
because it doesn't happen perfectly,
otherwise one or two people wouldn't be getting cancer.
So, but in reality, even though one or two people are getting a diagnosis of cancer,
even though that person got that has cancer, they had cancer
maybe hundreds of times in their lifetime in the immune system killed off those cells.
But there are some factors, kind of technical factors,
on why cancer cells survive in immune attack.
So here are some of those, some of these are little technical,
so I'm going to fly through some of them.
Ever one, most solid cancers express small amounts of tumor-associated antigens,
which they affect the dead-dridic cells.
The dead-dridic cells are cells in your immune system
that are differentiated into either killer cells or other cells.
So these tumor-associated antigens affect the differentiation of dead-dridic cells,
to become cells that are not killer cells, put it that way.
So, cancers themselves have the ability to influence immune cell production.
That's the key.
The cancer itself, as it grows larger and larger,
has the ability to influence immune cell production.
Number two, tumor cells tend to lack co-stimulatory molecules
that normally would drive an expansion and a progression end of your T cells, your killer cells.
So, they, even though in real life your immune system should see this growing cell mass as an enemy,
you have to remember that if I have liver cancer,
so one liver cell didn't go through apoptosis, and now it's in rapid replication.
Though it's not acting like a normal liver cell within the nucleus of the cell,
because the nucleus is affected, so it's in rapid replication.
It's not doing what a normal liver cell is.
It still is in liver cell.
It's not an enemy antigen.
So, your immune system is really traded.
I alluded to this in earlier presentations.
Your immune system is really trade to go against foreign bodies.
So, sometimes the growing mass gets to a certain size that the immune system recognizes it as a
foreign invader, and then it may be too large to kill.
We're going to talk about later too that as the cancer continues to grow,
the simple act of replication causes cell waste.
Well, rapid replication causes a lot of cell waste.
When you have replication of a cell,
and by no-cudreal function of increasing energy,
and production of energy, and all sorts of cellular functions that go out inside the cell,
there's a waste given off.
Well, that waste is expelled into the extracellular space.
That's the space between the cells.
When you have a cancer that's rapidly replicated,
that waste builds up quite quickly, and that waste ends up becoming like a protective layer of
slime around the cancer.
So, maybe you've heard it said that well, cancer doesn't grow in a acidic environment,
so I need to alkaline my body.
So, alkalizing your body could be very beneficial, especially if you're going to do it naturally with
juices and vegetables and things like that.
However, the truth is that cancer itself creates an acidic environment.
So, did the cancer grow there because it was acidic?
Well, I would differ with that.
The cancer by its rapid replication that's taking place is giving it off all this waste,
which is very acidic.
It is creating this acidic environment.
That acidic environment acts as a protective layer,
so the immune system can't penetrate that, especially as it gets larger
than you even have this greater waste,
to this greater slime layer you could call it.
Number three, there's tumor escape mechanisms.
So, different escape mechanisms get a little bit more technical,
but they have to do with collected three.
We have a big talk about that when I have a presentation on
turmeric that you want to watch.
So, don't miss that.
Turmeric is wonderful for breaking a collected three,
which collected three helps to help the cancer cell block
an immune action against it.
So, you want to get rid of collected three.
It also helps the collected three.
It also helps the cancer cell bind to other cells,
helps the cancer cells bind to one another.
So, it makes it more difficult for your immune systems to kill this mass.
So, the cancer cells are just replicating
and then that replicated cell is floating by itself.
It's replicating it because of adhesion molecules like collected three,
then those cancers are binding together into this big glob.
So, it makes it very difficult for your immune system to try to kill
that big glob of cells.
Usually a macrophage will literally engulf a cell to devour it.
Can't do that when the cell mass is 150 times the size of a macrophage.
So, how are you going to be able to kill that?
So, there's different escape mechanisms that tumors have.
Tumor cells also have shown to secrete interlocontid.
Now, interlocontid is a cytokine from an immune response.
So, now, interlocontid is typically a TH1 cytokine.
Now, a cytokine is a type of immune cell
that stimulates an immune response.
But, tumor cells to create interlocontid,
which inhibits the differentiation of dead-dritic cells to become killer cells.
So, dead-dritic cells, you can think of them as a like an immune precursor cell.
And, in the presence of certain cytokines,
then the dead-dritic cell turns into a TH1 cell or a TH2 cell.
If you could think of it that way.
A TH1 cell is your killer cells.
They're the cells that are going to, they're the marine core with machine guns.
The TH2 cells are the cells that reproduce that produce antibodies.
So, think of them as the FBI.
Well, you want your dead-dritic cells producing TH1 cells,
killer cells, macrophages that are going to help kill things
because we need this cancer killed.
Well, cancer has the ability to secrete different chemicals
that keep your immune-prescursor cells from becoming killer cells.
It's kind of crazy.
So, that tells you, well, golly, jeepers,
how are these cancer cells going to be killed if they're so smart
that they're getting your immune system
to turn off the production of killer cells?
Well, it goes to show that, kind of what I put in the initial part of my book,
is cancer?
You have to start after asking the question.
Is cancer a response to the body to stay alive
in a very toxic environment?
That's another theory that's out there.
How, if cancer is just the solely this bad guy that's a rogue cell,
that's gone bad and it's in a reproductive phase
and we need to go kill it,
then why does it have the ability to destroy my own immune system?
My own cell that has gone bad is, is gone so far bad
that has the ability to fight against my own immune system
so that it eventually kills me.
And then you have to start thinking about the other theories
of cancer that are out there.
Well, maybe it's because that's the only way
that those cells can stay alive in such a toxic maloo.
Meeting that if my liver is toxic,
do I have an increased chance of having cancer in my liver?
Well, we know that that is true,
but then we start asking deeper questions.
Maybe the reason why I have increased chance of having cancer in my liver
when it's toxic is because it's only a cancer cell
that's living in a hypoxic environment that's reproducing
the way it is that's conglomerated together
that can actually be a cell structure that can stay alive.
So it's a catch-22 because that will eventually kill me,
but I stay to live longer than my liver cells just simply all died.
And we just died by liver cells literally imploding and dying
because of such a toxic maloo.
There's nothing to prove it about that,
but it's an interesting concept to consider.
These cancers become very intelligent to be able to fight against your own immune presence.
So it seems to me that therapy should be aimed at trying to stimulate the immune response
and this immune response that we want to stimulate is that TH1 response
because it is the TH1 killer cell response that is really going to be able to kill the tumors.
Now I'm not saying that we don't need to think about debolking
and I'm not saying that we don't need to think about using some standard medical oncology
surgery or a chemotherapy or radiation, maybe in order in your case.
But after debolking, then we want to make sure that we stimulate the immune response
because that's the only thing that's going to keep it at bay.
That's the only thing that's going to keep circulating tumor cells at bay.
Also there's other ways to debolk other than the medical approach.
That's where the rif comes in and we'll talk a lot about rif therapy
because that itself can kill the tumor directly even all the way through the depth of the tumor.
It usually does kill the tumor from the inside out.
The problem with chemotherapy is grave.
We haven't gotten into that really and all of this lecture yet.
We'll be getting into that as we go.
Public chemotherapy does to your immune system is really the worst piece.
Let's just talk about that real briefly.
So we needed a immune response in order to fight cancer.
When we give a chemotherapy, the way chemotherapy works is it's a very, very strong toxin
and the reason why it doesn't kill all of us when we take it is that it's a toxin that's
attracted to rapid replicating cells.
It's a toxin that's attracted to rapidly replicating cells.
Well, that's good because cancer is rapidly replicating cell structure.
But so are some other things in our body.
Our hair follicles are rapidly replicating cells.
So are our immune system.
In a catch-22 with chemotherapy, we hope that we can give this poison
and because it's attracted to rapidly replicating cells,
that it will kill those things before we kill the person with it.
Because if you gave a person without cancer chemotherapy, you'd literally kill them because
you would just destroy their immune system and it wouldn't be attracted to cancer at all because
they don't have cancer. But when we give chemotherapy, we were trying to kill the cancer
right before we killed the patient.
The problem is it kills the immune system too.
So then we're having a fight to build that back up.
And it's the immune system that's keeping the circulated tumor cells at bay.
So what a person has been given a diagnosis of cancer, but the time it's large enough to diagnose
any way, shape, or form, it's already given off the hundreds, maybe thousands, maybe hundreds of
of circulated tumor cells. So circulated tumor cells are not yet rapidly replicating.
So since they're not that rapidly replicating, they're not going to be touched by chemotherapy.
So what's keeping them at bay from becoming a metastatic cancer?
Well, it's your immune system. When we give chemotherapy, it's killing the cancer,
hopefully, but it's also killing the immune system.
So it's also giving a huge opportunity for circulated tumor cells to take off.
It's a big, big, big stick in the mud and a really bad catch-22 with chemotherapy.
So we need to stimulate a TH1 response. So if you're going to do a chemotherapy,
we really, really need to stimulate a TH1 response.
And that's some of the therapies that we're going to get into in the next few presentations.
So anything that's going to aid in immune response, here's a donation,
garlic in these pictures, but because we need that,
increase in T lymphocytes, increase in natural killer cells,
macrophages, and synotoxic cells in our body.
That's all part of the TH1 response.
So next week, we're going to go into why I choose specific protocols and what ones I like best.
So I'm trying to keep this interesting, even though this is dry stuff.
So I apologize, and I'll see you next week.